Hello,
freak bitches to why?
Donald?
Why?
Getting off to anime?
Porn is shorthand for supporting Donald Trump.
Lauren Griffin had to say the name or worse or Sydney or Sydney.
Oh,
this just happened to pop up.
But what a bizarre fucking title.
Okay,
let's,
let's see what she has to say.
God dammit.
Forbes continue.
Please.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
On Tuesday evening,
gop consultant Rick Wilson made twitter,
but the waves with look at that,
they have the fucking stock of twitter right there,
plus zero,
50 percent,
zero point 50 percent in that hilarious.
They showed twitter and then they have people reading Forbes while will just
stalk at the stock number right next to it.
So weird waves with his claim that donald trump's supporters are mostly single
men who masturbate to Adam.
He's a gop consultant too.
I think they're right with,
uh,
this is unintentionally incendiary statement that Wilson says he made directly
to troll trump's followers.
February's trolling everybody.
First of all,
as any enemy fan will let you know.
It's called,
um,
clears throat.
Hentai a specific genre of x ray to Japanese animated cartoons.
But what's interesting is that in order to intentionally make people angry,
Wilson targeted anime Geeks as his insult.
Okay.
I don't know what this tweet don't upset them.
Yeah,
they'll.
They'll find you reply you.
I don't know.
I can compete with I,
I feel strongly that's.
I'm like,
okay,
I can compete with the girl I've seen.
I can't compete with cartoons.
Cellulite.
It's,
it's.
I really don't want to have stats on how many people have.
One website is convincing people to pay for cartoon porn.
If you're paying for cartoon point,
just watch Jessica Rabbit.
Whoa.
Hold on a second.
Among 18 to 34 year old viewers,
cartoon and Hentai are the 13th and 17th most popular porn searches.
And millennials are 131 percent more likely to search for Anamae than older
browsers.
Whoa.
You just blew my mind having her feet up.
Or do you think it was a sexual posturing thing?
I don't know if you know.
There's a lot of men in the room.
I'm in a weird position.
It could just be instinct.
Yeah.
Look at her.
Look at her dudes are staring a lot of black dudes.
Is that the Black Caucus?
Black College business leaders of the black historically black colleges and
universities and look at her.
Do you think that that's what's going on there?
I think that's very sexual.
I mean it looks sexual dude.
She's got the vagina curtain thing going on.
She's got her legs spread.
Yeah,
she's looking at her phone.
Maybe pictures of Dicks.
She's actually on tinder,
which is weird.
Yeah.
She's swiping everyone,
right?
Yes.
Come get some.
There's so many great memes about this.
Like I saw one of them that was in quotes.
What is a train question mark?
Fantastic.
That's fantastic.
We live in a fucking dream and we really do.
This is so to see donald trump's smiling like if you like knocked me over the
head 10 years ago and put me in a coma and then woke me up today and then.
And then I was like,
well what's going on?
Who's the president?
And you're like,
well,
check this out.
I'd be like,
get the fuck out of it.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It's like you remember that scene in back to the future when he's like,
who's the president in 1985?
Ronald Reagan,
the actor,
you know exactly what it's like.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It's great shirt.
Put that picture back up.
A camp.
So much going on there.
No one's ever done that before.
Like before this.
She's like,
we've got to do a photo with the blacks,
you know,
like the kind of things he says.
We got to get more images of the blacks that with me because every time really
important,
really important.
Every time he takes a photo into the Oval Office,
it's like 12 white guys.
Wish I could do an impression of him.
I mean,
yeah,
there's a lot.
Yeah.
To me it's just talk like it though.
I don't like.
My voice doesn't make that noise.
Like whatever noises.
He's his voice.
It's coming gravel or something.
I don't know what it is.
Yeah,
very bad things.
The bad debts.
Sad.
Very Sad.
That's sad thing.
It's hilarious.
The word sad after tweets because fucking everybody's doing it now.
So funny though.
The Internet is funny,
man.
The Internet.
The Internet,
you have to,
like I,
I always look at comedy,
like music,
you know,
and I always say like,
like I know how to do,
I know how to play Acoustic Guitar,
which is stand up,
you know what I mean?
And then how to write.
I've written for TV shows.
That's like playing the piano,
instagram,
twitter,
like it's like that's like the saxophone man and I'm like,
I'm trying to learn the music,
but it's funny man,
like people kind of common and people are good at it.
Like some people are just good at it and like you said,
you see a meme every now and then like my girlfriend sometimes we'll be in the
uh,
you know,
like whatever,
in the bedroom or something.
And I'm here hysterically laughing and I come in and she just shows me and I'm
like,
you know what,
that's pretty funny.
Just a still image with three words on it and it just works.
Well.
Memes are a new form of comedy,
like he's images with text attached to the end.
That's just so perfect.
Totally.
And there's a way to do it and there's a way not to do it because you can't be
met at about it.
You can't be like,
oh,
uh,
you know,
you have to like embrace it.
You can't think you're above it.
Like you can't go.
Like,
Oh,
here's my me,
my memes about how means you're stupid.
It's like,
no,
I'm not kidding you.
Everybody hates you.
I mean,
I've only made one instagram thing that I did.
Okay.
Which was a,
it was a picture of um,
Ivanka trump and that silver dress.
And I was like,
right when she released it,
I was like,
oh,
I gotta do something about this.
And I said to my girlfriend,
but what does this look like?
She's like a chipotle,
a Burrito.
So I found like I found a couple,
a burrito wrapped in tinfoil and I,
and I was like,
who wore it better?
It did really.
It was like the only time I did something and answer instagram because a lot of
times I'll put a joke instagram,
I'm like,
get ready Internet about to break you.
And then nobody likes it.
But that one,
that one I actually saw other people posting without crediting me and I was
like,
Hey,
what do you mean you don't really know their
dresses?
It looks like it looks just like she looks like a Burrito.
He's an odd look and fellow too.
There's something about the man,
the what does the name jared could lay low in the beginning,
you know,
like somebody doesn't us pick my battles dude.
You'd have to kill somebody immediately.
You have to find the first person in your group,
the weakest person and kill them in front of everybody else.
Yeah.
Like you can just stay on there.
Couldn't be like,
yeah Duh,
you can kill some dude.
But think about them and you can't stand there.
And as being a comment,
you know,
everybody's chatting group huddle and everybody's like,
you got to take somebody out right then because that's going to show your
dominance 100.
I mean it's going at least gonna show.
Like this dude is going to do something.
I see what you're saying.
But I think if you think ahead,
you would think,
well no,
they're not going to think that he's got arbitrarily gonna always kill the
weakest person.
Eventually it's going to get to know one because there's going to be the next
week is person,
that guy is dead now and the next week like who's to decide whether or not
you're weak or you're not weak.
If you were going to do that,
that person would have to be either a terrible person who is victimizing other
people.
Right?
Or they would have to have attacked first.
You'd have to be.
Or they would have been such a piece of shit that people are rooting for you.
Like somebody that was real chatty and you just ask them did.
There's no way I'm trying to survive like a,
like a,
you know,
the second coming of the universe in some dudes chatty in my group,
bro.
That's not.
Especially if like he fucks up some hunting parties.
You're out there with sneaking up on a pig and he's like,
oh my God,
it's so hot out.
You fucking pig runs away.
And everybody's hungry.
Yeah.
Chatty with you.
The first man I think about that kind of stuff,
like if a plane crashed,
I already know I'm planning ahead did I'd eat a Vietnamese guy?
Why?
Because it's easier to start or move.
If you attack somebody bigger,
you eat somebody bigger in front of other people.
It's going to alarm people,
but you got to eat a small person,
so stature is important.
I think if you come down a viet,
people aren't going to be that upset at you.
Other Vietnamese people are going to be super upset.
What are you talking about,
dad?
Their sacrifice.
They're more understanding of things,
dude,
this is the character you're playing.
No,
but if you eat a black dude,
you eat a black lady and her family's there.
There are going to be pissed.
So you think at Vietnamese person,
we'll let you slide.
I think that they'd be much more forgiving over a couple of day period.
I think a lot of their relatives.
You don't think so honestly.
One thing?
No,
I don't think so.
I definitely think that be super pissed at you.
Especially modernized ones,
but what is interesting is like Vietnam is one of the few places where Americans
can go back to Vietnam and they don't seem to hold any grudge at all.
Exhibit a
exhibit a man.
Honestly.